it's the three billion pound question
gripping english football which group of
billionaire financiers sports team
owners and celebrities will get their
hands on chelsea fc
the latest suitors as revealed by sky
news serena williams winner of 23 grand
slam tennis titles and lewis hamilton
the seven times formula one world
champion
the sale of last season's champions
league winners triggered by the
sanctioning of owner roman abramovich
kicked off only seven weeks ago but it's
already nearing the final whistle
the likelihood is that this is going to
run a little bit like the premier league
both top and bottom of the table is
going to run towards the end of the
season
the due diligence process
in any football club
these days is is a very is a very
tortuous one even when you're buying a
trophy asset
the uncertainty surrounding the blues
future has not deterred some of the
biggest names in finance media and sport
from trying to buy one of european
football's trophy assets
which means that chelsea's sale is
likely to become the most lucrative club
takeover in history
as well as its pair of sporting
superstars the bid led by samartin
broughton includes backing from josh
harris and dave blitzer two american
billionaires who own basketballs
philadelphia 76ers and the new jersey
devils ice hockey team
another of the offers is led by steve
palyuca a shareholder in the boston
celtics basketball side and larry
tannenbaum the nba chairman their
backers include the former disney chief
bob iger
the other consortium is led by the la
dodger's part owner todd bowley and
includes funding from clear lake capital
a us-based investment firm
it was here a year ago that a fan's
revolt against the european super league
caused it to be abandoned the backlash
will mean an independent football
regulator and tougher rules governing
who can own professional clubs but it's
also thrown a renewed spotlight on the
future earning power of clubs like this
and chelsea's next owners are unlikely
to be as generous as mr abramovic
a preferred bidder could be picked next
week with the sale taking place next
month after 19 major trophies in as many
years under mr abramovic there's no
guarantee that whoever replaces him will
bring a similar record of success
mark kleinman sky news